If you've been following my videos for the
last couple of weeks you will know that I am at
Disney World.
It's not that they've sponsored me or anything, it is
just where I happen to be on holiday.
Now, I've been avoiding Disney trivia
because, you know, it's a little bit
boring after a while but
there's something that my
cameraman for the week, Dan W,
-- Hello!
-- told me that I didn't really believe at first,
but he assures me it's true, I've looked it up, which is, well...
Dan, where are we currently standing?
DAN: We're at the Reedy Creek Improvement District. It's
Walt Disney World's own private
municipality.
TOM: Yeah. Essentially, Disney World has private cities
granted to them by the state of Florida
because they lobbied a long time ago when
they were buying all the land here and buying the space.
They have all sorts of powers: they apply for
planning permission
from themselves, they have the ability
to build all sorts of things, to
be immune from laws of the neighboring
areas that they would otherwise
be beholden to. Not only that, they have eminent domain,
as well, which means that they can seize small
amounts of land from around their borders
for their own municipality if they need it for
the public good.
And the startling thing is this: Dan, what
they technically have permission to build?
DAN: They have planning permission from
themselves to build their own nuclear
power station. It's in the legislation
from the 1960s still.
TOM: Now, that's because way back
when they were actually planning to build a proper city here.
And, while they've never actually built that
nuke plant – they have a small
oil-fired plant somewhere on property –
they had their own
runway briefly, they had all sorts of things.
There was gonna be a massive city here and then
Walt Disney died, and what we are left with
is the Experimental Prototype Community Of Tomorrow,
or EPCOT. But you never know, one day there might well be a nuclear power plant here
That is something
you might not have known.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]